[Musique]
camille marley bonjour bonjour monsieur
k o alors vous êtes candidat pour les
élections municipales à saint joseph et
vous êtes donc vous figurer au second
tour
saint joseph ou rousse et yan monplaisir
1 qui au premier tour a remporté le plus
de voix avec 42 90 % précisément des
votes
et vous camille alexandre marley puisque
c'est votre nom complet avec la liste
l'union pour la réussite de saint joseph
vous vous êtes classé à la deuxième
position de ce suffrage de premier tour
avec 11,77 pour ce temps pour cent et
donc on a une triangulaire pour le
second tour puisque il y a également
laurent saint-honoré qui lui a réalisé
11 37% des suffrages au premier tour
voilà alors qu'amy marley près de 30 %
d'écart quand même avec le candidat
sorti en tête du premier tour
n'est ce pas une distance trop
importante à à devoir combler pour vous
non absolument pas comme vous le savez
au second tour malheureusement la presse
n'a pas parlé à mon avis assez souvent
mais nous avons réussi à fédérer sur les
neuf lice au départ cette liste
donc si vous cumulez bon maintenant nul
n'est propriétaire des voix du premier
tour
mais si que vous cumulez la somme de ces
sept lits cela on est au delà et au
dessus de la défense des voix des voix
que monsieur mon plaisir à lever un peu
l'étau donc non pas du tout c'est pour
nous quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire d'avoir pu faire l'union
et je représente donc l'ensemble du jeu
et fait donc vous pouvez pas vous pensez
pouvoir rattraper ce retard
malgré une campagne quand même tronquée
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi le
contexte nous y reviendrons mais voilà
est-ce que ça vous a permis justement de
pouvoir parler à l'électorat de ses
autres candidats parce que c'est vrai
qu'on rappelle c'était le record de
candidatures à saint joseph un donc
évidemment à part appelé tous les autres
candidats qui n'ont pas pu se qualifier
pour le second tour mais ils sont
nombreux en tout cas il y en a
effectivement 6
donc l'électorat de ces six candidats
vous pensez pouvoir les récupérer
en tout cas le récupérer en tout cas dès
le lendemain du premier tour j'ai pris
contact avec ses six autres têtes de
liste et nous sommes tombés d'accord
vous fait une union et donc chaque
candidat fera une lettre d'intention que
vous allez vous recevoir
alors c'est pour ça que vous êtes
maintenu parce qu on se souvient que par
le passé bon plus tout à fait récent
c'est vrai qu'à minima relais je vous la
corde mais vous avez eu l'occasion de
faire cause commune avec votre principal
adversaire du moment
vous avez même mené des campagnes
électorales ensemble donc votre maintien
est ce que quelque part ça pourrait pas
finalement faciliter la tâche aux
deuxièmes du triangle laurent
saint-honoré c'est peut-être pour ça
aussi que du tout pourquoi vous avez
accepté
vous avez décidé de vous maintenir
plutôt excusez moi alors non mais votre
question n'est pas surprenante mais au
fait ce que je veux dire c'est que je
suis conseiller municipal de la minorité
de l'opposition je vois comme ça ça veut
dire entre 2014 et 2020
j'étais au conseil municipal de saint
joseph je n'ai raté aucun conseil
municipal sauf peut-être tandis que les
deux autres candidats ne sont pas sur le
terrain ne sont pas conseillés
municipaux
je rappelle que le candidat qui a qui
sont aussi en premier entre 2008 et 2014
a refusé de s'y joue au conseil
municipal
vous le savez donc en 2014 il m'a
soutenu
j'étais peut-être de l'iss loki c'est
vrai qu'il a mené la campagne avec moi
en 2014 et 2020 si vous jouez c'est
plutôt lui qui a mené la campagne avec
vous que vous avec lui quoi sert
exactement
et c'est lui qui aurait pu qui aurait dû
venir me contacter dès le premier tour
pour me dire qu'est ce qu'on allait
faire
donc il a décidé de se présenter tant
mieux je le souhaite bonne chance donc
c'est plutôt léger et votre maintien
vous pensez que ça ne peut pas faciliter
la tâche pour yan monplaisir face à aux
deuxièmes du triangle laurent
saint-honoré parce que vous êtes arrivé
troisième non je suis arrivé ce bon
second oui oui c'est ça à mon avis il
faut respecter ça tout à fait et qui je
suis arrivé en seconde position je vous
avais un score quasi similaire enfin
presque 1 11 77% pour vous
des suffrages et 11 37% pour laurent
saint-honoré oui mais je rappelle qu'en
2014 et justement je mettais un lien
avec monsieur vous plaisir
pas facile de mener campagne de second
tour
à saint-joseph comme dans toutes les
autres villes 1 là où auront lieu des
votes le 28 juin
pas facile de mener campagne dans cette
période d'après confinement voilà
comment comment faites vous camille
marley comme vous et comment vous allez
opéré dans les prochains jours non vous
savez une cabane aux élections
municipales c'est une campagne de
proximité
si vous ça d'ailleurs que nous sommes
alliés avec eux tous les autres groupes
quelle que soit leur tendance politique
et donc c'est une cabane de proximité
donc nous sommes en train de faire de la
proximité au niveau de la population
c'est ce qui compte
ça veut dire que si vous n'êtes pas un
homme 2-2 proximité ça ne va pas manger
c'est pou sak d'ailleurs qu'il ya une
grosse différence entre le candidat que
vous venez de d'indiquer et moi je suis
un candidat de saint joseph de la
proximité déjà c'est ça qui fait ma
force tandis que je ne suis pas venu à
saint joseph pour le servir de
saint-joseph pour aller ailleurs
vous comprenez je suis un candidat natif
natale de saint joseph merci camille
marley d'avoir répondu à nos questions
pourquoi
[Musique]